hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to an
edition of ask Evan today's episode is
brought to you by telus Hawks business
which is a great resource for
entrepreneurs looking for ideas and
motivation to grow their business as a
great blog attached to it which I am one
of the writers for so go check it out
and today's question is Matthew by one
of our readers dawn rodent asking Evan
can you respond to YouTube as a
marketing tool Thank You dawn so thanks
to the question Don I think a common
question a lot of entrepreneur thinking
about should I get into video or not and
will help me grow my business and I can
share my story I first started using
YouTube because I found that I was a
visual learner so I found I would absorb
more I saw video of something then if I
read syntax or listen to just an audio
only version so I wanted to be able to
share that with my readers as well and
my first youtube videos were of the
famous entrepreneur profiles and I found
that that was a really great way to get
the message across so whatever you know
probably service you're promoting
creating a quick video of it is a
awesome way to be able to communicate
that more effectively to people and
reach more people as well youtube mix
really easy to be able to go up there
and reach a big audience my first videos
I'm not on the video that much I say a
couple things and then there's pictures
that come up and this is my voice so if
I'm talking about a famous entrepreneur
say Oprah Winfrey I would come on and
say hey I'm Evan Carmichael in or do
this video on Oprah Winfrey and tell a
little bit of butter story and then
would cut the pictures of Oprah and
would be my force behind it so it's a
easy way to kind of first get into video
if you're not too comfortable in front
of the camera my first videos were
pretty bad too in terms of the quality
with the camera and you can go back on
my youtube channel and look at the
history I haven't deleted them but the
content is still great but the quality
of the video is pretty bad but that
that you learn as you go and do more
videos since then i found that now i do
a lot of videos answering questions just
like yours and at first when people
would email me questions or write them
in the farms on blogs i would always
write a response and i found that that
was really great and it really helped
that one person but i wanted to be able
to help more people and i found it
through the videos people have the same
question so that one person has a
question there's you know thousands of
other people who also have that same
question so by creating the video I'm
able to help a lot more people and
hopefully the person I'm helping to I
can help more intensely because they're
getting a video version of instead of
just a written written quote by me so I
try to release a video every day now on
my youtube channel and I usually filmed
them once a week on a Wednesday morning
and then they get scheduled up to go out
during the week but that's been a great
way to also build a connection with my
readers so they can see me instead of
just you know reading reading my my
content so if you're trying to build a
connection with your audience and being
established as an expert people like to
work with people they feel they have a
connection with and they people like to
buy from people on set of you know
corporations or you know people who
they're not sure who they are so having
a video is great way to be able to get
your message across so I'm not sure what
what part of the service your kind of
cell but they would definitely be a
great idea to create a welcome video
explaining you know who you are why you
started your business tell your story a
little bit get people hooked it involved
and the longer they spend watching the
videos and longer they spend on your
site the more likely they are to take
whatever next step you want them today
if it's you know sign up for your
newsletter buy your product hire you for
a consulting project or whatever it is
so it is a great way to help you do that
if you look at landing pages those with
the video have a much higher conversion
rate typically than those without so
again people like watching the videos it
helps keep them on the site longer it
helps convince them and answer the
questions such a few you know are
friendly and have a nice smile and
look trustworthy then they're much more
likely to convert people to take
whatever next step you want them to take
the last thing about YouTube that really
like is it's it's own search engine and
we get a lot of people who view the
videos because I send them to the videos
and I promoted on my blog at the social
media but a lot of people find it
through a YouTube so we try to optimize
the videos for different keywords and
new people are finding me who would
never found me before so they searched
Egypt directly in YouTube or these
YouTube videos are showing up in the
Google results when you type in whatever
keyword so it's a lot easier to rank at
least right now for YouTube video than
it is in the regular Google search
engine so that's another great way to be
able to get your message across is to to
create the videos so I love YouTube I
think you should definitely check it out
and try it out I wouldn't spend too much
money on it and and you don't
necessarily have to have a really
high-end production value I think it's
more important that your authentic and
genuine and you get your message across
as long as people can see you and hear
you one of the big mistakes I made
earlier on was not having microphone so
people said we love it but looking we
can't really hear what you're saying so
that's a great boost as you can have a
microphone but yeah just simple
production get your message across be
authentic and people will want to watch
it and hopefully take that next step and
and no buy your product hire you in
consulting get excited for newsletter
whatever it is that you want them to do
so hope that helps done and you know
again thank you to tellus arts business
for sponsoring this video if you have a
question feel free to leave it below I
always try to answer those or if you
leave a comment on one of our blog posts
on color socks business I always try to
respond to those ones as well and of
course if you like the video please give
it a thumbs up it makes want to do more
of these videos for you guys so thank
you and you'll see you on the next
episode
you
you